ein mahnmal des krauts das ehemalige kz
auschwitz birkenau
im süden von polen am rand der stadt
von 1940 bis 1945 töteten die nazis hier
mehr als eine million menschen
die meisten davon waren juden
er hat lange zum holocaust geforscht
pavelski kulturanthropologe und kurator
in warschau im internet stieß er zu
seiner überraschung auf verkaufsangebote
von postkarten aus auschwitz
auf dieser karte steht auf polnisch ich
habe es ja doch nicht getroffen
küsse dich und hier müsste grüße aus
auschwitz und theresa eine der für mich
schockierendsten karten ist diese vom
inneren
auf der rückseite steht mit wärmsten
größen aus auschwitz von den nachbarn
das sagt mir etwas was vorher für mich
unvorstellbar war die person die diese
karte ausgewählt hat hat offensichtlich
auf gar nichts geachtet wieder auf das
bild noch auf die bildlegende
acht jahre hat schiphol ski gezielt
gesucht
heute zählt seine sammlung etwa 90
postkarten die menschen aus auschwitz in
die heimat geschickt hatten
die früheste datiert von 1947
nur zwei jahre nach der befreiung des
vernichtungslagers
es ist nicht schlimm ist dass menschen
diese postkarten verschicken
es ist viel mehr aussagekräftig dass sie
dies taten es bedeutet nämlich dass
menschen die nach dem krieg diesen ort
besuchten darin auch ein urlaubsziel
sehen konnten sagt etwas aus wenn ein
ort an dem hunderttausende von menschen
umgebracht worden zum touristen
anziehungspunkt wird dann erzählt dass
etwas darüber wie wir geschichte
begreifen können
inbesondere in einem völkermord nun
lässt die polski auch die öffentlichkeit
an seinen entdeckungen teilhaben
eine zufällige begegnung mit dem
schweizer verleger patrick frey hat zu
diesem buch geführt
greetings from auschwitz versammelt
abbildungen der abscheulichkeit des
nationalsozialismus versehen mit den
harmlosesten grußformeln wie sie von
jedem beliebigen ort hätten geschrieben
werden können
auschwitz birkenau wird heute von 4000
menschen täglich besucht ein ort des
gedenkens
aber der umgang mit der schweren last
der geschichte gelingt noch immer nicht
allen gleich gut
immer wieder tauchen auf plattformen
sozialer medien service aus dem
ehemaligen konzentrationslager auf so
etwas wie das aktuelle von dort zu den
postkarten größen der vergangenheit
ich habe bewusst den fokus auf die
postkarten gelegt weil sie etwas
wichtiges über uns menschen die nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg leben erzählen es ist
nicht ein neues phänomen nicht nur die
kids von heute verhalten sich so es gab
es schon zwei jahre nach dem krieg und
in den museumsshops werden bis heute
solche karten verkauft aber die besucher
machen sich offenbar mehr gedanken was
sie darauf schreiben
ich wollte auf jeden fall hinten einen
text schreiben vielleicht was ich dort
zu erlebt habe und so das hat auf jeden
fall jemand schenkt so habe ich mir das
überlegt aber jetzt per post schicken
jetzt haben sie postkarten gekauft ja
schicken sie diese in die heimat ich
werde mir selbst diese karte schicken
und meine erinnerungen an diesen ort
niederschreiben
erst am schluss meiner arbeit als das
buch schon fast fertig war habe ich eine
karte kaufen kein auf der jemand von
einer der schlimmsten erfahrung seines
lebens geschrieben hat erbe beim besuch
dieses ortes realisiert was dort
passiert sei aber dies ist so etwas wie
die skurrile ausnahme
verglichen mit den hunderten an berg
hatten greetings vom auschwitz ist ein
befremdlicher gruß aus der vergangenheit
in ein heute der bilderflut
wer einen ort wie auschwitz besucht kann
ihn nur über vertiefte
auseinandersetzung erfassen
ansonsten ist manche reise hierher
vergebens gewesen